[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to the design
singapore council webinar
delivering on a sustainable design
intent
following through on a sustainable
design intent isn't always easy
but there's no time to waste in tackling
climate change and other sustainability
issues
what are the biggest barriers to
achieving more environmentally
sustainable buildings
cities interiors and products are there
viable ways to overcome
the barriers when do top-down
regulations need to be bolstered by
bottom-up sustainability initiatives
today a diverse panel of designers is
tackling the many
advocacy ethical and economic factors at
play
in the pursuit of sustainable design
this session is being presented by the
design
singapore council or dsg supported by
the national design centre
as singapore's national agency for
design dsg
champions the use of design to grow
business spur innovation
and improve lives we hope to highlight
pathways to fulfilling those aims
through the crucial lens of sustainable
design during today's panel discussion
we are extremely grateful for the
participation of an outstanding panel of
speakers from the built environment
and product sectors so i'd like to
extend our thanks to them
for sharing their time and insights
today razvan gillick miku from hassel
panya cheng from produce emily simm from
panalog
yvonne so from the singapore green
building council
and benjamin tell from the building and
construction authority
i'll let you all know a little bit more
about them shortly
i'm narelle from dsg and i'll be
moderating this discussion
and i'm pleased to tell you we've had
audience members from around 20
countries register for this session
encompassing designers design
enthusiasts and business executives
which is a really exciting prospect for
a diverse and cross-border discussion
i'm looking forward to it so thank you
for joining us and please do send
through any questions you might have for
the panelists at any point during the
discussion and we'll
endeavor to get to them all so from
need to have to nice to have so
easily the best intentions can have
their associated sense of urgency
diminished
when inconveniences or barriers to their
achievement arise
but how are we all collectively
assessing what is acceptable when it
comes to sustainability performance
in designed outcomes and in the
management of how we operate
according to the world green building
council buildings and construction are
responsible for around 40 percent
of the world's carbon emissions in the
furniture and product industries
with some impressive exceptions it's not
always easy for specifiers
to access transparent sustainability
credentials
some are certainly making good progress
in adopting new processes for
sustainability
for many business as usual continues
even though the prospect of reaching
global warming targets seems always
further out of reach
when it comes to barriers and
inconveniences designers and all project
stakeholders have a responsibility to
interrogate
interrogate whose inconvenience is
really the issue
ours or future generations and
importantly
what action do we need be it top down or
bottom up action
to change our course
today's session was conceived with the
intent of proactive discussion
rather than lamentation as a way of
getting at the heart of the issue of
sustainability for the design industries
we want to look beyond greenwash to the
grit of what typically
gets in the way of delivering on a
sustainable design intent
to do this we've brought together a
spectrum of professionals whose activity
ranges from the areas
of advocacy to policy practice and
production
i'll take a moment now to introduce them
by sharing their bios
you'll see some quite solid blocks of
text on your screen now but i'd like to
read through our speaker's bios in full
in order to accommodate the breadth of
their agency in terms of pushing for
sustainable outcomes so
do listen in because their their
experience may might give you some
really
great fodder for proposing questions to
them later
first of all razvan gillik miku is an
associate at hassel
he's an architect with a keen interest
in innovation and agility
and an advocate for resilience by design
at hassell he's involved in designing
new generation
working and mixed use environments in
singapore and across australasia
he's a graduate of princeton university
with over a decade of professional
experience in singapore shanghai new
york and toronto
rosvan balances practice with ongoing
involvement in the singapore institute
of architects where he serves as the
chief editor of the singapore architect
magazine
and he also leads a design studio unit
at the national university of singapore
pan niching is the design director and
co-founder of produce
established in 2013 produce was set up
as a design studio
with a prototyping workshop to deliver
highly robust and bespoke
design solutions from concept to
construction
since establishment producers completed
a number of highly acclaimed projects
including wild rocket keiki suites and
the little drum store and monoform
living
prior to this he graduated with honours
from the architectural association in
london
and he was chosen as one of the top
eight uk graduates in
2006. he's accumulated more than 10
years of working experience in the
fields of architecture and academia
working with firms such as arab advanced
geometry unit
tp bennett siri architects and un studio
next is emily simm who's the director of
panalog
the company endeavors to shift
production and consumption patterns so
that builders designers and
architects can create spaces where
ecology and urbanization can progress
in parallel having graduated from
singapore management university and
undertaken an apprenticeship in sumetomo
forestry japan
emily now works with individuals brands
and government agencies
on the selection and implementation of
sustainable builds and regulations
she currently serves on the board of the
singapore furniture industries council
as an executive committee member and
previously as an executive committee
member of the singapore timber
association
yvonne soh is the executive director of
the green building council
singapore green building council or sgbc
which is an industry organization
founded on strong public private
partnership
to drive the transformation of
singapore's built environment
prior to joining sgbc she established
the operations of the waste management
and recycling association of singapore
as its first executive director evon's a
registered professional engineer
a civil engineer and a green mark
accredited professional
she has an extensive experience with the
government sector having been with the
building construction authority for a
decade heading the center for
sustainable buildings and managing
portfolios in
policy development regulatory control
industry promotion and research and
development
evon's passionate about driving
corporate action on climate change and
the development of programs to
motivate and sustain a virtuous cycle of
action
and finally benjamin henry towel is a
senior architect
at the building and construction
authority he's an award-winning
architect policymaker chartered surveyor
and chartered environmentalist
he's a respected thought leader an
assessor of buildings and districts for
their environmental
performance he's a senior architect
within the environmental sustainability
group of the bca
where he's been involved in the
development of singapore's environmental
policy within the built environment
sector over the last decade
including the development of green mark
2015
and directing the response to advancing
net zero energy
through the super low energy or sle
program
he's also the author of the singapore
institute of architects green book
and he was previously the chair of the
world green building council's
rating tool task group he currently
holds the urbanization and planning
strategy seat on the royal institution
of chartered surveyors governing council
so welcome everyone and thank you for
being here and let's get into our
discussion
i'd like to start by setting the context
for our discussion and getting a sense
of what each of you are bringing to this
conversation
through your professional activity so as
i ask questions of each of you it would
be great if you could include your
conception of
the term sustainability in your response
i'm going to start with yvonne so yvonne
the singapore green building council is
a non-profit organization
with an advocacy agenda and its own
certification schemes
for green building related products and
services
could you give us some background on why
the singapore green building council was
incepted
under whose charge and what gaps it's
been filling in the green building
ecosystem
in singapore since 2009
uh good afternoon everyone um and
thanks narelle for that introduction
um well i guess there are two key
reasons why
um the singapore greek building council
came into
existence firstly in 2005
bca launched a green mark scheme which
is a framework to
rate the environmental sustainability of
buildings
and in those early days there was a
great need to learn about
and adopt the best practices from around
the world
and bca would convene an international
panel of experts every year
to advise bca on the path that singapore
should
take well it turned out that almost all
of the appointed experts were also
local leaders of their own nascent
national green building councils
and they encouraged singapore to set up
a national green building council as
well
as a more efficient and effective way to
be connected to
global best practices and to keep
abreast of the latest developments in
green building
so bca got together a group of
early singapore green building advocates
formed the committee of course
provided seed funding and also secretary
support and that's how
the singapore green building council got
established in 2009
so that's like our short history in a
nutshell
but seriously the second key reason why
uh next slide please the why green
building councils exist
is because delivering and operating a
green building
is a collaborative effort by many
different professions
and members of the supply chain where
the building is
our final collective product so
the singapore green building council is
the only organization that brings the
various players together in one place
all with the common objective of making
an impact and delivering buildings that
are more environmentally sustainable
for the benefit of people our members
come
from all sectors including also the
financial institutions
recently and uh i would say
diversity is the strength of our
membership and we
use this strong point to facilitate
conversations and
partnerships yvonne thank you for um
your response to that first question
i'd like to ask you why did the
singapore green building council see
the need for its advocacy and
certification schemes
and why is singapore green building
council the right body to administer
them
okay so well um the green mark scheme
was established by
uh in 2005 and it
uh very quickly i mean bca very quickly
got
inundated by requests for meetings from
solution providers who were very eager
and excited to share their ideas and
technologies to deliver better buildings
and push the envelope for green
so it quickly became apparent that a
central repository was needed to seive
out the
suitable solutions for singapore and to
create an efficient
marketplace for green building products
to connect with specifiers and
project teams we also have to bear in
mind that
uh singapore in singapore we manufacture
hardly
anything right so we have a wide choice
of products from across the world to
bring to singapore
and to choose who we want to do business
with so do we want to
be a responsible global citizen and
support businesses that are operating
sustainably and manufacturing products
that are to the best of standards
that will enable our buildings to
perform better or do we want to
settle for less so i think that's uh
something that we
asked ourselves and that's why the
product certification was uh created
um for our services certification uh
that's for professional consultancy and
contracting firms
and this was launched two years after
the product certification scheme
it was a natural progression as green
building gained
traction and building developers and
owners
not just in singapore but also in the
asia region
wanted to know what firms had the
capabilities and expertise to develop
deliver green buildings the singapore
way which is a building that responds to
and fits the tropical belt that we are
in
our latest certification program is the
green accredited
professional program which is the
professional qualification scheme
for building profession uh building
professionals to profile their
capabilities
and then to your second question which
was about whether we are the right body
to administer these schemes
i guess i would say yes because of how
we are
set up we don't represent any one
particular
profession or trait so we have no
obligation to promote any particular
sector
and also we have very strong support and
participation from the public sector
so if you look at our board every single
public sector member on the board were
elect was elected in by
our members and during elections they
also have to provide their election
manifesto just like everyone else
okay that's good um some accountability
there
good to hear okay i'm going to um
uh throw over to ben now and ben i'd
like to ask you
about the sie green book that you
authored
and what was the vision that you had
when you authored that book for the
singapore institute of architects
because when i read it what i'm reading
is a
really urgent call to arms
yeah um essentially that's that's what
it is it was um
a call to arms for the profession at
large
um given that architects are involved um
throughout the project you know for its
entire life
in many cases you know other consultants
come and go but the architect will
will have that site or be involved you
know across
the lifespan of many buildings and many
projects
so it also positions the profession as
being aware and
engaged with the
full issues of sustainability but it's
not just about being aware and engaged
it's also about
ensuring that there is a positive
response and action
um to the facts that are out there the
the book is also
quite important in that it features a
lot of
projects you know from the local
fraternity
demonstrating that the singapore
architect is already skilled at
addressing these issues and it
highlights some beautiful projects from
all sides of practices from your one
one man sole proprietors through to your
um you know locally established
multinationals so it kind of covers all
of that so
next slide um
the the book next slide uh the
the book provides an overview of of
climate change as well
as developments in international
environmental law
uh and of course uh the finance industry
which are normally considered in silos
and separate subjects and something that
the profession at large be it architects
engineers tend not to get involved in
those discourses
and stay a little bit away from from
those worlds so
it provides a commentary on how those
are all interrelated
the changes that are occurring across
those different spaces
and and how it's coalescing into the
professionals world and
and it's a kind of we need to keep track
of this we need to be aware of this
and those that start to engage in this
will actually see the benefits
and those that don't could be in for a
rough time both professionally
in terms of future liabilities and in
terms of accountability
and in terms of you know understanding
the market and getting projects
so next slide but beyond the theory
um the we we have the edgs which are the
environmental design guidelines now
these provide
practical uh guidance for both projects
uh and the practice itself for the
implementation of the new urban agenda
and the the united nations sustainable
development goals which a lot of people
talk about
but they're all very kind of up there
macro level
objectives it's how do we bring that
down into professional practice it's
distinct from a rating
we're not talking about a rating tool
here we're talking about attitudes
behaviors decisions discussions and
things like that
so on the next slide you can see what
those actually are
so it labels us to have a template to
demonstrate our role uh in bringing the
sdgs into life into all of our projects
and you know a guideline for us to
measure what success is communicate with
our clients
and work with our practice and our
allied professionals to
to connect and utilize and join the dots
and work out how things all
go together and and finally um
on the last slide um you know these are
some of the project images that you'll
see throughout the book
but it provides a critique so it doesn't
try to hide
that you know architects in fact the
built environment industry across the
entire value chain
you know much of our work is entangled
with
and complicit uh to the multiple
uh drivers of earth system destruction
and
we haven't been sufficiently ambitious
to deal with this
you know as as a fraternity uh and i
still think
that we're not so we kind of need to
look at those
roles that we have in urbanization and
economic growth and
and what is the role that we want to
play and we can't preserve the status
quo so the
throughout the book you know it really
identifies that we cannot preserve the
status quo of practice
if we do we need to be comfortable that
we are
and accept the responsibilities that we
are preserving the root causes
of the you know sociological destruction
and crisis that we find ourselves in
today
that's it i found it quite exciting to
to read this kind of position from
a professional institute so i think
that's a tremendous step
ben you've been a critical actor in the
ongoing development of the bca's
green mark rating scheme and the push
towards net zero buildings
with super low energy so why are
top-down incentives a necessary part of
the green building ecosystem
in your point of view
well i i mean let's be honest we don't
the market doesn't value um good
necessarily in in the full terms there's
a there is a disconnect between
environmental concerns and damage and
and the cost of things on the value of
things that's why
we have a proliferation of cheap
disposable items you know
go to the hawker center you know
sometimes it's actually more cost
effective for the hawker to
give you things in disposables rather
than
in a reusable plate which then has
manpower to clean and things like that
so
the value system that we have in place
doesn't quite
communicate the real cost of
environmental damage
of many of our activities products
services and approaches
and don't forget the the kind of whole
carbon
based economy has been around since the
industrial revolution so that
that's had almost a century uh with more
than a century sorry now
uh to to work out how to be very
efficient at pricing things and valuing
things through that way without those
considerations so
you know to steer that ship to a new
economy it's going to take a lot of time
as such top-down regulations and
top-down incentives are required to plug
that gap to
to start to to move that juggernaut a
different way which wouldn't happen
naturally otherwise due to that
disconnect between
uh value uh and real value and
and real cost versus perceived value
perceived cost
and on the topic of incentives i
personally don't like incentives i think
it's actually a bit it's a bit addictive
um you know it can change the market to
be
i need an incentive for this or i'm not
going to do it kind of mindset
which i'm not a fan of but then again i
understand
the need for it it is that recognition
of value to try
and you know push that something good
which wouldn't happen
otherwise in the current market
mechanisms um to get over that initial
risk to give the proof of concept
and and then something like a building
there is high risk
because it's not a product that's going
to be in your pocket for a year or two
years it's something that's going to be
there for decades so
any fundamental change in the way that
we do things it has an inherent risk
and also a lot of a lot of cash with it
so
that's kind of why we need quite a lot
of top down but of course that doesn't
and shouldn't inhibit a bottom-up
approach as well
yeah the the risk part is yeah an
important point that you've raised and
um
especially in terms of how we view the
time scale of projects and what our
roles are
so one one last question for you at the
moment ben what knock-on
effects have you seen singapore's codes
having in terms of elevating
the ambition for sustainable urban
building or interior design outcomes
so i i'm not here to give everyone a
concur actually
a congratulatory uh tap on the back um
but uh you know greenmark
as a whole whether we love love it or
loathe it
has been a linchpin for much of the
environmental policy
uh successful environmental policy
that's come out in singapore and it has
been very useful in attracting
international
awareness it's transformed our market
quite significantly
obviously we have the support of our
green building council which help us
with that
greatly it's that kind of partnership
that brings industry and people together
so as a government intervention
which greenmark is it's been really
successful like that
it's been an agent of change uh in that
policy space yes you could argue that it
was to
it is too quantitative it doesn't value
design as much as it possibly could but
you know it it it brought a lot of
people along with that journey and
created a new market
and a new value system
for products and services to really
start to move things along
and in terms of nuts and bolts you can
see that
there's a new vernacular of building
that has started to come it's not
mainstream yet it's in the niches but
it's becoming more and more prevalent
there is that steering of
of a singapore building you know when
you walk past it it's got a lot of
greenery on the outside
there's a it's started to work with the
climate a lot more
it's a lot less air conditioned it's a
lot less of a
of an american glass box you know built
for nowhere implemented everywhere
it has a that real kind of exciting
design to it
that hasn't really been here since the
late 60s early 70s with the pioneer
architects that did golden mile
people's park pearl bank which were
local uh
vernacular of the modern movement so
we're starting to get that now
and i'm not saying that's all down to
government policy and all down to green
market things like that
but i think greenmark is helping to to
drive those ideals to
that wider audience and providing that
recognition
and again that's the kind of approach
which we're seeing regionally being
applicable
so our policies our approach our ideas
and thus our consultants
and the brand sg and those intangible
values are being brought
out and brought along so we're seen as a
bit of a leader in this front so it's a
great opportunity
yeah i agree with you it's exciting to
watch how singapore architecture is
developing with
um vegetation with climate set
sensitivity
okay ras fun i'm going to turn to you
now
the practice that you are working in
hassel has announced
last year that in it had embarked on a
carbon neutral road map
for all of its studios worldwide and the
fast tracking of its gift to renewable
energy to power
its studios so what prompted these
changes to hassle's practice management
all right well that's a great question
narelle um
and i think the question was prompted by
by an image that was broadcast on our
various social media streams i think
late last year announcing the shift
and hopefully we can get the slides up
as well um to see the image
but frankly that's that's nothing really
new for us because we we have had a
present
sustainability function in hassle for
well more than a decade at this point
and it is really about promoting
environmental sustainability not only
through the work that we do but also
through the way that we practice in our
operations
and a few years back we we were already
around the 60
mark of of using renewable energy and
around 2018
we we started a new sustainability
framework
uh that encompassed a whole bunch of
measurable targets that we were going to
achieve
and that was the five-year plan at least
back in 2018 so looking at 2023
but if we go next the i guess the
accelerator
um and in a way a catalyst has been some
of the natural disasters
we have witnessed across the globe of
course australia was
on fire about a year ago and also our
increased leadership role
in in this conversation through
architects declare for instance
so we decided to actually bring that
ambitious 2023 goal
forward and our australian studios have
reached it by the end of last year
and we're working towards the rest of
our studios
achieving it by the end of this year so
that's in a nutshell sort of where we
came from
and what made us push it even harder we
just couldn't wait you have to leave by
example
here are more firms taking steps like
this
well and you know that's that's pretty
hard to gauge
um i only work for one firm but i guess
extrapolating for our own from our own
journey um there is a bit of a lack
of easily available information and
actually you have to have
you know create a deliberate focus on
looking for this information
that could be a reason but for us i mean
speaking just for ourselves i can see
perhaps two main factors that drove and
really enabled this change
and one is you will see on the slide
that kind of vanished off the screen
and i'd rather very much look at it than
at myself um
it's is our people it's been there's
been really tremendous
interest from from staff all across the
practice in making this shift
we're talking about my generation older
and and definitely the younger
generation
who will have to inherit the mess that's
being created right now
and we want to practice in a responsible
way so that's in a sense to echo some of
the
thoughts that ben had just mentioned is
you know this this is a true bottom-up
approach where
that's how we to get as a collective we
choose to practice
but the other one if we go to the next
slide there's also a top down
it is simply what we do as a practice
you know what's your mission what's in
your dna
and it could be through the sectors that
we are active in
for instance this one about
environmental communities the projects
that we do
that's a screenshot from our website and
also the conversations that we choose to
be part of
for instance archifest just a few months
back
and i guess the danger when you look at
it is to really succumb to this fallacy
of oh we're just the practice we won't
really make a difference
but you know leaving it to the other
people mentality you know
you know other people can fix it people
with more power people with more agency
um so we decided to fight that very
simply you know we we decided to get
our house in order first to think global
but
really act local and if everyone does
that in their own kind of gets their own
house in order
you can imagine as it aggregates to
something that could be meaningful
okay i'm just mindful of time so i just
would ask you
quickly to touch on one more question
hassel was
also a founding signatory of the
architect's arm of the construction
declares
in singapore which has spread from the
uk to i think 26 countries so far so
could you tell us about hassel's
commitment
to that declaration and why the firm is
taking ground up steps like that
so yeah we we we did join the uk charter
with our architecture landscape
architecture teams
if you go next slide please we we are
amongst the seven uh local practices
founding it here in singapore
we're also a founding member in
australia and architects declare is
really
we saw it as a rallying point for
architects to come together to try to
address these issues of climate change
and biodiversity loss and although the
commitments are somewhat aspirational um
they're entirely worthwhile
and is the way we choose to practice and
chose to practice even before aligning
with architects declare
and joining it is also about catalyzing
and encouraging other parts of our
industry and other practices
so if you go to the next slide i'll give
you a peek behind the curtain
um you know the commitment
going back to the first question you
asked you know commit committing to
something that's somewhat measurable
these targets is also a good chance to
figure out
how to get there you know with intent
and some level of accountability
and here you can see an actual extract
from the sustainability framework of how
we run
our internal design reviews for every
single project in the studio
so developing that internal compass was
really crucial to promoting a mindset
that is genuine
and and not expect that complying with
codes is enough
and again i'll have to bracket that with
the fact that we do practice
across various jurisdictions and codes
vary but having that internal
authentic compass is really core to how
we design and how we choose to walk our
talk
okay thank you rasvan yichang i'm going
to turn to you now
so you change your studio produce is
currently undertaking
research via dsg's good design research
program
and this is for the development of a
mass-engineered timber product
could you tell us about that and what
pushed you in that direction
and your plans to produce it in
singapore including
the capabilities here for manufacture
and workflow
yeah so our company we have invested
in a prototyping facility for a number
of years
so we have always practiced phase one
design and make
primarily at first it was to overcome
the
the shortage of skilled labor
particularly in carpentry in singapore
and then gradually we turned into doing
prototyping for
larger and larger installations and now
we're looking to
create outdoor installations as well as
buildings
so um what pushed me in the direction is
also to find
a kind of synthesis between all the
three companies that i have
so superstructure is doing digital
fabrication
um type zero is my architecture firm and
produce does design research and we look
for an opportunity to work in the center
um so next slide
um and we have been toying around with a
lot of uh
kind of prototypes and particularly our
interest lies a lot in timber
one is uh because we're limited by the
tools that we have
and secondly it offers the kind of
design freedom
that we can then combine with digital
fabrication
and also uh timber is the only renewable
building material and um so for
the dsg
good design research mix like these
we wanted to capitalize on the kind of
protest
positive potential of met adoption
which is the integra integration of
digital design
and fabrication to assembly workflows
increase the productivity
and reduction of manual labor and
creating a carbon neutral
construction method but our product
is based on reconstituted timber which
is different
from normal met
so what it builds upon the additional
advantage
is that we want to create something that
sell a
relia a self-reliant met component that
is sourced from
our region in southeast asia using
plantation timbers such as rubber wood
and then it will also reduce the
plantation to product and around time
because it's
faster to harvest and then it reduces
the material
and increase strength to weight ratio uh
for our product
and uh in the end we want to encourage a
more widespread adoption of
mit construction in singapore and uh
within the region
so we go to the next slide um so our aim
is really to
look into reconstituted timber as
a base material and allowing for digital
tools and computational design to
create more possibilities and
at the same time to work towards a kind
of
system and component based design
that will allow a more widespread
adoption of met and particularly to
replace concrete
i was going to ask you yuching um you're
developing this sandwiched variable egg
crate structure
through your research project at the
moment
i'm wondering how would that be dealt
with at the end of its life and
does singapore currently have the
capabilities to deal with a circular
approach to mass engineered timber
um so for the product that we're looking
at it
reconstituted timber at the end of this
life
i mean the first priority is to reuse so
we want to look at it from a component
point of view so
for example something like that which we
are trying to fashion into a
wall or floor panel can then be reused
in another site
then after that it can be also be broken
down and reconstituted with
other other materials to form finishing
panels
or building materials that are a
kind of lower intensity in terms of its
structural strength
um but the circular economy is
definitely important but i think we need
to look at the
not the end of the cycle but the
beginning of cycle
which is to first of all
look for the correct source
of material from a sustainable source
and look for materials that are that
contains high recyclable content
and low hazardous content and is that
easily done
sorry is that easily done in this region
finding that
source material yeah i think we we first
need to
start and then there would be a supply
when the the building goes to end of its
life then
there will be a supply of recyclable
materials that can then be repurposed
but currently
because of the lack of it we don't have
the
diversity of industries and
manufacturing capability
to start to look into the the afterlife
of material so
what we are trying to do is completely
bottom up in a sense we are
trying to start this process um by
uh investing our time to research uh
uh into this component uh met component
yeah in use could it be used for
furniture or other avenues as well
well definitely our priority is still
to to develop materials for
buildings um but definitely can be used
for
furniture and perhaps even
surface finishes or decorative panels
within buildings for interior use
okay well all the best with the
development of that product teaching
thank you
and now i'm going to throw it to emily
emily i'm going to ask
the first question to you could you tell
us about the product ecosystem that
panalog sits within here in singapore
and in the region
and the steps that you've taken with the
company toward an alternative offer to
impact so what what kind of gaps in the
market are you addressing with panalog
thanks narelle so the name panel log is
derived from the words panel and
dialogue which
means to start a conversation about
engineered flat panels
and the meaning is multiple first we
want people to focus not only on the
surfacing material by what's
underneath the furniture but also the
start of conversation about engineered
wood
products being an equal alternative to
solid wood
so this enables us to extend the
possibilities of woodworking
what we are doing is to essentially
shift the demand from traditionally
sought after
things like solid wood to what's
innovative
so if you move on to the next slide most
engineered materials
come in panel form and it's easy to work
off it's
the most sustainable of all being
plantation logs
and they help us increase the abilities
of wood firstly the yields can be
increased from
40 to 60 percent when we are producing
solid wood but with engineered wood the
yield is
often above 90 percent and with
engineered wood we usually remove all
the traditional disadvantages of woods
like it's
knots and cracks spreading them out
across the panel
so you can slice and chip them easily
and it increases the number of
applications and that's why you see like
an uh my red of new like timber
skyscrapers that
is popping up all over the place uh
panel materials are also the most easy
to ship
so it really helps us reduce carbon
emissions as well
and on to the third slide you can see
the engineered wood products is tailored
to all kinds of applications so for
designers i think it's good to start the
conversation and think about how you can
express these new details
that come along with engineer wood the
material is more stable we can use them
for digital fabrication to generate more
complex geometries
or we can work with less material and
increase the span of our designs
so at parallel we provide this extra
consultancy and help the designers to
manipulate this new materials
so emily do you think that the
singapore's furniture sector
is doing enough to tackle sustainable
production
in singapore and the region and how
about you know distribution and life
cycles
and is there enough demand from
consumers and specifiers
for more sustainable offerings when
southeast asia is concerned we are slow
to act but it's definitely a hot topic
that is gathering traction
uh it's largely led by new rules and
regulations but awareness
all takes time now and government
agencies and associations have been
trying their best to rule out policies
but these policies will sometimes affect
the cost of living so
i think it's a precarious balancing act
so despite singapore being a small
country we are responsible for one
percent of the world's furniture
production spread across the region so i
think it's extremely important that
singapore companies
take the lead in creating sustainable
business models
where fsi sfic comes in is to help
singaporeans
singaporean companies roll out this and
adopt these new initiatives certificates
and best practices
set by different organizations across
the world so that no one is left behind
and from here we have the visibility of
all singaporean companies
exploring different routes towards a
more sustainable and environment
environmental friendly practice our
members such as office planner
a home-grown furniture supplier has been
applauded by the singapore environmental
council for their efforts to go green
through the use of recycled materials
they've also been awarded the green dna
award for their efforts
and there in the slide you see another
home-grown financial brand commune
who moves not only to have their
products crafted with recycled materials
and ethically sourced wood but their
furniture is also designed
with the intention of minimizing waste
so sfic is currently working to onboard
members
in view of nea's new mandatory packaging
reporting framework
where producers of packaged products
especially furniture such
big and bulky items will be required to
submit packaging data
this will really help companies raise
awareness about
how much packaging they're using and the
benefits of reducing the amount of
packaging
being used and regarding product
life cycles i think we can definitely do
more there is really no effective way
to simply recycle furniture because
singapore furniture is
made up of so many different components
that must be stripped away
stripped apart and recycled individually
designers have a role to play in
building making building materials more
sustainable by
making it more durable more easy to
repair
refurbish reuse and disassemble
so this to maintain their components and
their materials to the higher
use highest useful purpose as long as
feasible
which minimizes resource waste
so the responsibility of end-of-life
treatment of furniture is also
requires a concerted effort from the
consumers to find out best recycling
practices
and for government companies or
companies to make this available option
to all of them
so i know it's a tall order but the
sustainable design intent should not be
seen as an advantage by the prerequisite
of their design
and sometimes the linkages are not very
clear so maybe i'll highlight a few
environmental issues that are connected
to work of an interior designer for
for example uh deforestation
and to encourage that engineer would use
plantation lock products and use only
solid wood
where necessary and ensure that they are
produced in a sustainable way so on the
topic of let's say like a
resource consumption uh create like a
fashion form
minimalism is one approach that could be
designing for like multi-purpose
furniture kitchen appliances
replace could be replaced with machines
that perform different tasks
so this would minimize the amount of
things that we need
and of course waste as i've touched on
before
designing something that lasts with
minimal packaging
and provide viable disposable options i
fuse is something the designer needs to
look into
and the less direct kind of linkages can
be like carbon emissions you know
choosing materials that are
near where you live having your
production close by
or other creative ways like you know
creating new
uh things that that help collect rain
water or examine like the raw materials
that we are using and make sure that
their
manufacturing process uh are not
polluting their environment
so i think these are important so if you
move on to the next slider you can see
that you know manufacturers
use so much and and they need to really
innovate through like innovate through
refining their manufacturing processes
be
open to new technologies and make more
informed choices so they are also
there to inform and enable designers to
create something
completely sustainable and different and
lastly
and the most obvious reason is to not
cut corners i know that cost
implications can be very very difficult
and
these decisions to make can be quite a
lengthy one
so i and the last answer
sorry yeah and the decision that is
going coming from the management can be
a lengthy one
but i hope that they make the right
choices for the environment
and lastly and the most important point
is to educate consumers
so i know that like uh consumer demand
has a great role in driving sustainable
offerings
and sustainability unfortunately cannot
be seen
so usually it's the first to go when we
talk about
cost cutting for cost conscious
consumers or manufacturers
so we hope to change that by being an
agent of change thinking of how
uh designers and manufacturers can
affect that change
um and if you think about it you know
like we talked a lot about
renewal energy but nobody talks about
renewable building
materials renewable furniture and that
kind of stuff so that has
really has to be brought into the
limelight so that we can start this
conversation without having
renewable interior spaces
yeah thank you emily
so i'm conscious of the time and i'd
like to move to the next part of our
discussion
so for this part i'd like to really get
to
the barriers to sustainable design
so it's i'd say it's really not possible
for anyone
these days to claim ignorance about the
need to combat climate change and embody
sustainability
and you know there are a lot of things
to concern us from the prospect of
climate breakdown and biodiversity
collapse
economic and social collapse that might
come with new inequities
um you know uninsurability of properties
or projects with a high embodied risk
that's related to climate change it's
kind of a scary prospect which ben was
alluding to earlier
so we do need fast and collective action
but not everyone's taking that path
and not everyone in the design sectors
is either willing or able to advance as
needed
so let's talk about the barriers now
i'll throw this question to anyone in
the panel is
upfront project cost really the biggest
barrier to delivering on a sustainable
design intent because it's the factor
that i've heard
mentioned the most frequently why is it
often
more expensive to take the sustainable
route
you'd like to tackle that shall i have a
role
yes it won't yes okay
i mean um well for us because we've been
at it for
uh 10 years right i would say i
i really don't think that cost is a very
big
issue these days because many corporates
are setting sustainability as a key
objective now
i find that maybe it's more if you're
using new solutions and
innovative solutions then that's of
course um a premium
when you when you try something new but
cost very
quickly comes down with uh economies of
scale
so i think because we certify quite a
number of innovative products and in the
early days uh the companies would tell
us that's an issue with demand but
um schemes like the green mark you know
helps to
encourage take up so
one two years later when i talk to the
same companies you know that's not an
issue
and i think when it comes to designing a
building it's more about the planning
uh having giving the designer sufficient
time to to plan for a good building
and cost is less of a factor i would say
yeah okay
does anyone else want to feel that
yeah i'll just i'll decide to yvonne's
point i i think that that's right
i don't think we can get away from the
argument on cost but it's the argument
on cost
if you try and do something exactly the
same way as
as before so if if you design a big
glass tower which
is fully air conditioned and then you
want to go
now i want it to be a more sustainable
building
then you're going to incur a great cost
attack creating a
you know trying to solve a problem you
have created in the first
instance whereas if you pull it back to
first principles and say well actually
if i was designing that project for the
climate in which it's
but i think the point is that if you if
you have a problem of your own making
and you try and resolve it it's going to
cost you money
if you do it from the fundamental
principles work with the climate for
example
you're going to have something which
doesn't cost as much
could be cheaper um you know
and much more effective it's about the
sim doing the simple things right which
then allow you to take the risks with
new technologies and things like that
new technologies yes they do carry more
weight
that's everything but like i said if
you're designing for first principles
you need a lot less of those
technologies in the first place so then
you can
you have that freedom to experiment the
freedom to apply
and so you can you can do it well
without the extra cost
yeah this one as well is that cool
oh yeah please go ahead
yeah slowly one by one right um
yeah i think it's it's also a matter of
separating the notion of cost
to that of value i think a lot of times
we are
somehow conflating the two and they
couldn't be further apart
and i think having that real
conversation
at the beginning or even before the
beginning of the project with
um with your client with your
consultants and
really set the direction around that
notion of a value and a long-term
investment because i think a lot of
times and perhaps that is decades of
being conditioned to practice a certain
way
there's this bad habit of of um
starting like you were saying ben just
starting perhaps out of inertia
a certain way on a project and then
trying to somehow either fix
or reverse some of the issues that you
come up with or to just kind of
you know put the bitter pill in a apple
pie and try to kind of swallow it that
way
whereas i think sometimes the impatience
of
of waiting for for those gains that are
actually incremental and they take a
long time to manifest versus
upfront quick savings is also something
that needs a cultural change in the way
we develop cities and beyond because
obviously capital cost is one but
operational cost
life cycle is another thing so looking
at the way that efficient
systems that somehow in the longer term
actually absorb a lot of the upfront
cost without producing all the negative
side effects
can be a strategy that everyone has to
have buy-in because
again buildings are an investment that
is for decades
and it's not simply a quick real estate
play you cash out
that's the end of it it's someone else's
issue to deal with so it's slightly more
systemic
um and i think slightly more complex
than just just
price uh price point itself yeah no
you're absolutely right
value value is something that is is
neglected the value
of good design the value of doing it
right
versus the cost and i i don't think we
do value the value
of good design enough we can't put a
dollar value on it
per say as easily when it comes to an
audit which is
which is a shame because we should be
valuing that that design that
the lifting of the spirit of a good
building versus
a a not so good building for example
there is a value to that or there's a
value to planting trees along roads
it costs a huge amount in terms of
upfront and maintenance but there is an
intrinsic value to it
so on on valuing that value i'd like to
ask
um are there procedural barriers to the
financing of sustainable projects and
i'm wondering about things like
the ability to assure or to prove
outcomes
and things like inconsistencies in how
data is collected
so yeah barriers to the financing of
sustainable projects
can we talk about that
who's willing to give that one a go
i can i can give it from a high level
point of view but in terms of
financing projects obviously being in
the public in
in the policy area um i i don't have
much direct kind of experience where i
can stay where it
seems to be going and then hopefully
others can can talk about some of their
projects and how those have been
financed or
the things that they're seeing but um
in terms of finance at the moment
there's a lot of issues regarding due
diligence
and obviously but financers don't want
to be
seen as green washing so they're quite
worried about what they invest in
when it's said to be something
sustainable
so sometimes there's a procedural cost
of actually trying to you know prove
that something isn't green washing
versus
the actual thing itself so both in terms
of time and
and energy um you know but that said
there is
becoming a more apparent taxonomy
to sustainable linked finance and gold
standards such as the eu taxonomy
then you've got the fact that climate
risks are starting to be priced in
through
tcfd which is not just looking at
central banks anymore
but have spread to to corporations and
how they value and
things and and look at their assets and
portfolios so
it will take time for that change to
happen but there is
kind of changing in the way that finance
will be structured that you'll soon
cost more to finance a project that
doesn't
have sustainability objectives or goals
or
you know metrics as part of it so you'll
start to see
that that move into the space
okay let's um step back and take a look
go ahead right i was going to chip in on
the financing
of sustainable project obviously the
green mark
lays out a wide spectrum of
design standards to achieve the required
bare minimum result but let me talk a
bit about the uh
met and body carbon point of view
um currently uh uh and i also will be
talking a bit more representing small
firms doing small projects because a lot
of
all these projects falls under the
requirement to submit for green mark
and therefore and i would say this this
account for
quite a large stock of buildings in
singapore
where small practices actually do not
have the opportunity to practice
um in in sustainable
design i'm not talking so much about
the operational or maybe passive
cooling but more in terms of the
targeting embodied carbon reducing the
use of concrete let's say
so um
what yvonne pointed out about the
economic economy of scale is true
we need that to drive down the price and
as small practices when we look at one
house
at a time it's not possible to to gain
that
economy of scale and so i believe that
um
we need a collective effort as well from
all the small practices
maybe even to pull resources together so
that we can all practice in
let's say in the met department
of sustainable buildings
okay i'm going to jump to another
question
do we think that systemic change which
is apparently what's needed
is going to come from policy from a
public movement
or from both the top down and the bottom
up
big question well i think it'd be unfair
to uh put the policy
makers on on uh on the spot right now so
maybe i'll i'll answer because i i kind
of alluded to that
in in some of my remarks earlier which
is
both end um and again i think you know
in singapore obviously we are
very fortunate to have a a regulatory
body that
has a great degree of um sort of
impartiality and fairness um that cannot
be
the same cannot be said about other many
other markets where different
bodies that do regulate um sort of
different types of of assessing green
buildings and whatnot
do have affiliations that make some of
their decisions somewhat dubious
but i think without and something that i
i
i picked up on something that um pan
said as well
and and then earlier and if on which is
again the whole point of of of having
conversations
as a profession is to push above and
beyond
those regulations and and really
understand what
the value of good design is for each of
us and collectively because
if you look at even many buildings that
were designed
before green mark really even existed
that were based on
uh really sound principles of how to
deal with passive cooling or heating
with thermal mass with material
consumption um when they were
retroactively assessed whether for for
sustainability even for
what we what a lot of the conversation
has shifted towards which is wellness
um they score very highly without having
had those codes in place
so i think it's it's almost like a bit
of a wake-up call that we shouldn't use
it as a crutch
um to just comply with and i think it's
having this conversation to me is great
because you know you know you have
you have um you know representatives of
top down but also bottom up
so i think it's it's working hand in
hand rather than kind of just leveraging
and waiting for the next code to tell
you what to do
and and then just kind of leaving it at
that but for that to happen i don't want
to take more airspace
is it something that yvonne would
mention earlier which is
giving the right amount of time if we're
expecting to create innovation and value
in a way that's entirely new with a set
of challenges
and environmental disasters that are
posing completely new threats
we cannot run the same old business
model at the same expectations of time
and cost
as we have for decades so i think
actually
balancing that that that problem is
something that's probably very important
moving forward
yvonne would you like to elaborate yeah
actually i totally agree um that
you know today what i see is that the
bottom the bottom
the bottom up is really leveling up
right i mean in the past
um the industry takes a lot of uh
direction from
bca and you know what the regulators
want but
what i've seen in the especially in the
last
one and one and a half years uh private
sector is really leading in terms of um
wanting to do the right thing so um
in addition to construction d class the
world green building council has a net
zero carbon
buildings initiative and i think they've
already signed on 130
organizations leading from you know the
cities regions
all the way down to corporates
so there aren't many simple names
in there yet but i can tell you that
there are some of our companies that are
really looking at it because it's quite
um an onerous commitment
um that corporates would need to
ensure that the entire portfolio of
buildings that they operate
uh operated at net zero by 2030 and then
new buildings
um training
new building 2030 and all buildings that
they operate by 2050
so that this will cascade down to a
number of
initiatives and support programs you
know for the designers
for the solution providers you know to
to meet the demands that their clients
are asking for
so um yeah i think it's a collective
effort
and um things are changing the private
sector is uh
really pushing the government now
okay yeah that's um i'll actually align
the the bottom up is leveling up
do we think that um that
we still need a greater value being
placed on the branding and the
reputational benefit that would come
with demonstrating best practice
uh definitely i think to be realistic
a lot of the large companies need that
recognition framework
it's an easy means to communicate to
their investors so we have to understand
that i know there's a lot of pushback on
green washing and all that but
if you look at it from the the genuine
corporate viewpoints they do need some
external validation
that uh what they are doing meets
certain external targets so i think the
role of government is
very important sometimes in providing
some of this
recognition of best practices
there's a question from an audience
member and this
comes back i think to what we're valuing
how do you strike a balance between
using
green technology in the design of
buildings and letting nature take its
own course
for example the audience member says i
always think that
modern airport terminal buildings are
being built too big
especially now it's a much bigger
conversation about
loads of people and procedures and so on
but
would anyone like to respond to that
audience question yeah
striking a balance when using green tech
and letting nature take its course
letting nature take this course is a
great idea
but we are talking about like more than
50
of the world population moving in the
cities by
i don't know something like 20 i mean we
have already crossed the 50
mark and by 2050 if we don't have
climate neutrality uh we will not be
able to reverse
climate change i think that's the target
and therefore
uh importantly now is to build
um you know in a more sustainable way
with
carbon neutrality and this uh
this requires a very um
systemic change to to the way we build
um to the to the very material we use
and
i think i think that's why i i am
particularly
passionate about um pushing the timber
agenda forward yeah
okay i've got another audience question
here do you think that covert and the
impact of
social distancing and lockdowns whether
that's on
economies on supply chains on real
estate is going to help or hinder
efforts to achieve
sustainable design
that's a loaded question so i better be
careful how i uh handle it
um it's it's it's interesting because
it could almost like reverse in the
short and long term
so you know the videos that showed up on
youtube
you know after a month of lockdown with
the canals of venice
being clear and the skies above major
cities
um north of where we live um also having
you know
a bit of sunshine and blue skies so in
the short term
obviously there is a direct correlation
between
things being affected by kovi the way
they have and
a a perceived amelioration in climate
but
as we as we know you know correlation
doesn't necessarily mean causation
um equally you know markets are trying
to bounce back
um after that and there's a lot of
questions around especially now
in in cities and that could be a very
dangerous path whether
uh density and and urban centers are a
failed model
you know everyone's fleeing not for us
we don't have much choice but everyone
in other countries is fleeing to suburbs
and so on
um so i think obviously what kovi well
the recent sort of covet pandemic and
it's still raging on another in many
other countries
is it's really making us rethink the way
cities spaces programs work
i am personally because information that
comes in research scientific research
that comes in is so different almost
week by week
i am personally afraid of knee-jerk
reactions
and major changes in sort of the way we
imagine the future of
and you insert your own kind of special
category whether it's cities whether
it's high-rises whether it's workplaces
it will have an impact but it will
probably not be as
seismic and immediate as some of those
early kind of videos seem to suggest
it's just a matter of
understanding how to deal with the
information we have at hand
and be able to pivot as more information
comes to light
i think emily was trying to speak a
couple of times
did you want to add anything emily
oh i was about to add on to yvonne's
like the previous question regarding
branding like other than like rewarding
uh rewarding uh companies and
organizations for their green efforts is
also sustainability is almost invisible
when the consumer is buying something or
when somebody is using so i think that
like
branding with clear graphics and all
that really brings
value to uh what this kind of materials
bring on the table
and also like um because there are so
many competing materials right you're
really not comparing
apple to apple on any certain in any
certain situation so
it's really good to really cut through
the noise and also for the
informed consumer to make a good
decision about which
material best suits the case
yeah that's a great point you've raised
emily about
the ability to compare apples to apples
on
certain materials when you're selecting
them or on a
certain product so how can we
overcome this barrier and i'll put this
back to all of the panel
what can we do to make sustainability
efforts more transparent to consumers
it seems like we need to keep raising
awareness
of sustainability among the consumer
population but
often it's not very transparent what can
we do
[Music]
pay people have to pay polluters pay
there's a disconnect i i'll bring it
back to waste isn't it
you know it costs how much to produce a
polystyrene tray
how much to sell it and then because we
all pay for that disposal through our
taxes
um you know it goes somewhere and we all
pay for it so
there really needs to be that
understanding of
the cost the true cost
of production of consumption and i don't
think until
until that's caught up because we we are
literally paying
for the production of something not none
of those externalities
so the pollution to the river gets
picked up by someone else
the illnesses caused get picked up
generations later again
by someone else the toxic waste
the the landfills all of that gets
picked up and paid for
by someone else it's not the
responsibility
of the producer so i think
the only way we can really address this
is through that and of course then there
are the circular systems which come into
play
because once the cost of that comes out
you have circular systems which suddenly
make market sense because if i don't
have to pay for disposal because i can
keep reusing
or i have my technical bin and my have
my
nutrient bin which goes into the ground
great the my technical bin can keep
being reused reuse reuse over and over
again
all of a sudden that makes economic
sense so
that disconnect needs to be fixed
um okay if i mean share in the product
world
um something that's really coming up is
uh the environmental product
declarations
so this is something like uh what we
have you know the nutrition label
for for food so it breaks down
the impacts of a product uh you know in
various ways
it's uh carbon emissions as well as um
uh impact to waste streams and
end of life issues and all that so i
think this
this is um uh it's there's a strong
movement for it
uh in maybe europe u.s
it's uh coming to asia so we've been
looking at that
uh but for us in our product
certification scheme we've been
emphasizing on the carbon footprint of
product is a very good starting point
and we've been educating all
smes in particular on it yeah
okay we've touched a little bit on the
ethics of
consumption you know packaging and all
the rest
let this be my last question to you all
because we're
rapidly approaching 6pm do we need to
also have a conversation about the
ethics of
design practice you know who whose
responsibility responsibility
is it ultimately to target and achieve
sustainable design outcomes
who'd like to tackle that
yeah emily go ahead yeah i was saying
that like everybody
on earth has the responsibility to to um
for sustainability but definitely
designers like um having design and
build the
world around us uh should
almost always have some expert domain
knowledge so like i really feel like
designers should be
have a role as asian job agents of
change
to educate the population i know it's a
tall order but uh
sometimes the linkages are not very
clear so definitely like we have to
um kind of understand what goes into the
material what's waste
what's uh what's result what's the topic
on like resource
consumption
that's a nice line that you said emily
designers need to be agents of change
i'd fully agree with you any other panel
members
like to chime in
it's everyone's responsibility at the
end of the day
and whether we like it or not our powers
as say architects or as designers
is not what it once was you know whereas
before
we had patrons and people will just go
right you're the architect
i want a building of this size over to
you
now there's a lot greater complexity
there's a lot greater
uh well less there's a lot greater
i say brief in terms of what the
what the client actually wants you know
it's kind of i want something like this
which is like this these are the
constraints so of course the designer
has the skill and can do it but it has
to come from everyone
from the brief from the financers
investors who
have a lot more power and a lot more say
in design than than ever before
it it's no longer the designer left to
their own devices to design and do
wonderful things it's
there's a lot of you know layers
which which kind of impact and they all
need to be
educated uh to the value of sustainable
design
and probably i guess as a designer and
looking at the evidence of centuries and
decades of designers being left to their
devices maybe is not the best idea
to begin with um but i may have said
earlier and i'll repeat it um
is that mentality of don't wait for
someone else
um and you know if you if you cannot
prove
that you can't get your house in order
whether you are a one-person shop
whether you're a multinational um an
inch it from there then there's really
no hope
and i don't want to sound um dire at the
end of our conversation but
frankly it it it literally is up to
everyone but
also everyone within their own kind of
you know
courtyard just to you know sweep it make
sure it you you really understand what
you're up against
yeah okay everybody i'd like to thank
you sincerely
audience thank you for your questions
and to rasvan yi chung
emily yvonne and ben thank you sincerely
for sharing your insights
bringing you all together with your
diversity positions
in the design industries is a really
valuable discussion exercise so thank
you very much
and we're nearly at the end of the
session so i hope you've all found it
valuable
and thank you once again for joining us
you